hi i'm benjamin hermann and i will be
showing how you can perform
resolvent analysis using time result
flow field measurements exclusively
and without recourse to the governing
equations
this is work presented in a recent paper
titled data-driven resolved analysis
which i wrote in collaboration with
peter badou from imperial college
richard zeman from to branch bike steve
brunton from university of washington
and beverly mckeon from caltech the
paper is available on archive and you
can find a link to it in the description
below
so say you have a linear stable system
that's being periodically forced then
the long term response
in the frequency domain is governed by
this expression
where this is the resolvent operator
this operator encodes how
any disturbances to the system are
filtered by the linear dynamics
to produce a response in the context of
non-normal systems
we know that the resultant behaves as a
very selective
amplifier of disturbances and because of
this
it is critical to understand the
dynamics of such systems
this was first pointed out in the work
of trypathen encounters
in the context of shear flows since then
there has been a growing interest in
using this method
mainly due to its relevance to the
design of flow control strategies
by using the input output framework
developed by jovanovich
ambami and also to do its relevance to
identifying structures and scale
interactions in turbulent flows
by using the interpretation of
non-linearities as forcing
proposed by mckeon and sharma and even
though
we know it's important and there is this
great interest from the community
in applying resolvent analysis to flows
with two or three inhomogeneous
directions this is still not commonplace
and one of the main reasons for this is
that resolvent analysis requires
under hood access to high fidelity
numerical solvers of the linearized
governing equations
in this work we develop a purely
data-driven method
that can work with black box numerical
solvers and doesn't require
access to adjoined solutions
so it opens up the possibility of
eventually doing
resolvent fully from experimental data
so now we'll be showing you how does the
method work
and for that i will be using data from
direct numerical simulations
of plane channel flow and all the
details of the numerical setup
are in our paper the first step
is to collect a sequence of state
snapshots
from recording of a transient simulation
starting from a perturbation uh to the
stable system
so in this case the state corresponds to
the
three velocity components in this
three-dimensional flow field which here
i'm visualizing as
velocity iso surfaces
then we can enrich our data set by
considering
additional recordings of transients
starting from different
initial conditions
the second step is to assemble our data
matrix matrices
which is just stretching
the state into a very long vector and
horizontally concatenating these states
according to your temporal sequence
followed by the temporal sequence
corresponding to the next initial
condition
and the next initial condition and so on
and actually the ordering in fact
it's not really important what's
important is that all the columns
in the y matrix correspond to the
columns in the x matrix
but everything shifted one time step
into the future
and the f matrix that you see there
is just a waiting to adjust the inner
product
so that the l2 norm measures a
physically meaningful quantity
which in this case is the perturbation
kinetic energy
now that we have these matrices we use
dynamic mode decomposition
to approximate the leading eigenvectors
and eigenvalues of the underlying linear
operator that involves our measurements
and we use this learned eigen
decomposition
to build our resultant operator but
projected onto eigen coordinates
and we perform resultant analysis so the
singular value decomposition of the
resultant on these coordinates this
projection of the resolvent
was first used by radiant henningsen a
while back
in 1993 where they used it to
reduce the computational cost of
computing resolvent gains
but in their case they used
the actual eigen decomposition of the
system from a known operator
whereas here we're using learned
eigenvectors and eigenvalues
that we learned from data using dmd
so the last step is to synthesize our
resultant modes back into
physical coordinates so if we had
enough data we we will get
a good approximation of the actual
resultant modes
of the system and here i'm showing the
optimal forcing where i'm showing
a world normal velocity iso surfaces
and the optimal response for channel
flow where i'm showing
stream wise velocity iso surfaces
so these are the familiar stream waste
voltages causing stream west tricks
and here are some more results so these
are the operator-based
resultant modes just for ground truth
comparison
and these are the ones obtained from
data using a data set
that was generated starting from these
initial conditions where this middle
plot
shows the learned dmd spectrum overlaid
on top of the true spectrum and these
are the data-driven resulting modes
for this data set we needed to retain
200 dmd modes
to get this approximation now
what happens if we use the optimal
forcing as an initial condition to
generate our data set
well in that case we only need 20 dmd
modes
to generate an even better approximation
of the true resolvent modes
and what's more interesting is that we
are actually learning a very
specific region of the spectrum
which is something that we noticed so
the last result that i want to show you
is what happens when you use a localized
disturbance
as the initial condition to generate the
data set
here we're using this doughnut-shaped
perturbation which is
something that resembles what you would
get in an experiment with a
well normal jet so in this case
we get these modes which are
quite different from the true resultant
modes
so this the question that arises is
are these results useful how do they
relate to the operator the actual
operator of the system
and how can we interpret these modes
it turns out that if we do an
operator-based resolvent analysis
but where we restrict the input and
output spaces
to be in the span of the data snapshots
then we get the same modes so this means
this is very encouraging because
it means that these results are still
very valuable
we just need to be aware that what we
are getting are these forcing and
response modes
that are constrained to live in the span
of our data
which completely makes sense okay so
these are some points that i want to
leave you with
first this data-driven resolvent
analysis
inherits its capabilities and
limitations from dmd
so computational cost noise robustness
data efficiency all depend on what dmd
variant you're using
also we want to point out that
we found that it's very important that
we develop
more effective ways to explore the state
space
of dynamical systems
i also want to point out that this is
the first step
towards a fully experimental resolvation
analysis
and we believe that this work
contributes to lowering the barrier of
entry to resultant research
and applications and finally
a final remark is that we recognize that
there is still a critical step
missing before we can make the leap to
data-driven resultant of turbulent flows
which is we need to disseminate the
linear from the non-linear dynamics
and that's actually something that we're
working on at the moment
okay so thanks for watching again there
are a lot more details
in the paper and you can find a link to
it in the description below
thank you